уду поведінку травневого розгадки на сам
їсть ринки за знач вночі про те
українську армію воюють як мінімум дві
праві екстремісти групи імперський
легіон то русич он і видами ти масив
живі вали на донбасі в 2014 це 2015
уроках і дражнячи лисята діас аблаїв і
жорстокістю і відправив він і брали
покладених ним по різанні легіон
цивілізований підрозділ ультраправого
прикро не російські імперські рушники
включені США то канаді до списку три
різних організацій осі у процесі
вдома експертом просто вірджинії польська
рук переважно схуднути і
санкт-петербурга
до Петра міг дружити з низьким з
петербурзьким відділенням партії батьківщина
чоловічим відділенням партії батьківщина
води разом організовував і різьблені вони
ці заряди
домагалася я розвороту на
міжнародні види
лідер російського campari спині руку на
адже богу і дні кілька уроків у тому
виступом на консервативнішій платформі на
платформі консервативні але нас Аліна
скільки я розумію на лікарі емоціях дайсі
зрубують і знову геть і кілька років там
організувала і гітарний то берпі називаю
партизанів та якщо у лані троцький лопаті
десь у ленінградській області та туди
запрошували навіть тут і запиту води на
вид іноземних ультраправих активістів та
так залишилося ще двоє активістів століття
проходили підготовку у тему таборі якщо
поверну не до швеції на що воли серію
терактів влаштували серію терактів ніж
можна каже і пройтися серйозних
плавно у нас та стінах та довгою у
україні чепра їх невисокий учительок
експерти так і обожнюють каприз проби
вербувати і при клініці максом а може і
запит сотні людей пити годину і провину на
донбасі 2014 15 мм уроках ви награли
значить вбити роль вони були
призначений обидві щоки або кістки в 14 15 там
уроках він та російська федерація
траплялося про саму на добровольці я
кибли готували хати нас немає україни то
висновки на
схід україни та воювати готовий навчання
створ і т.п. на ви дамі серця воюють не
російська скроня а miss even a check the
cis апарат з таких часто називав їх
ополченцями в череді баловні білизни по
вимогі zara zara stand з я їх з
добровольці лсд beach huts відомо
такі російські скроні звичайно все-таки
російські війська і все-таки сам факт
участі whinin' його нацисти з
російської убавку робити абсурдну явну
причину провини так дзвінок денацифікації
україни призначено до поведінку травневу
розвідки проти чого б дві сторони
регулярного хрестову терміни та фашизм та
нацизм мета діалоги на гра не
особливо його кермо побачимо призначаємо тонше
купців прямо і завалитися мої біди
нотифікації на вигляд майданчик абсурдно
явно кулі дорівнює тому що це навина по 6 в
ніж шість антифашистських, що дуже вже
його боку чи іншого боку фашисти тут у
загоні не чергову роль, а не з того вони
чув боці на гра або з того боку
грають тисячі було і завжди ультра праве
на базі Російської Федерації c fag
1000 ультра праві були на будь-якій Україні.
так вже факт але це чимало ціна 100 суйся
суті природи та її провини
наймаючи вигляд ніж і не сам та я каюся
ультраправу ідеологію з диким через
стережі ними червоним ми можемо його бари ти
про я гусь їм з реалістичного вина
який-небудь
імперіалістичної очного що кейс
диким і зі сторожами алла цінна і так
логічно вина скажемо про фашизму проти
антифашизму тут а в залі фашизм треба
винести за дужки вінні чорний пояс
знаєш ти нічого іншого рішення і в
зрештою нічого не вирішують про те
що відома відведу не починай про не у нас
і стимулах російської армії db, але в
будинку конференцію barlinek ким там за
означав ще на кімнату бути за видами у
її спецслужб